hi I'm Jane fountain and I'm the
director of the national center for
digital government and a professor at
UMass Amherst in the United States and
I'm here at the world economic forum we
just ran a fabulous closed-door session
on new media in the future of government
and an answer to the question what keeps
me motivated it keeps me motivated is
carefully observing and shaping and
sometimes having an influence on the
connection between new information
communication technology social media
and how governments are run how to make
them more effective how to make them
reach out to their people how to bring
civil society and the voice of the
people into governments try to reduce
inequalities both in the so-called
advanced countries and also throughout
the developing world work so it's great
session